foreign
[Music]
tro I don't know how to joke about this
Drew Barrymore is a scab what does that
mean what am I talking about well
let's not waste too much time let's get
into it as you are no doubt well aware
especially if you watch this channel the
sag-aftra and wga Strikes are continuing
in California and New York and wherever
they can set up a picket line in March
uh where they feel it is necessary to do
so in an attempt to get fair and livable
wages for performers and for writers of
the entertainment we all love this is a
difficult battle it is ongoing I do
believe they're going to win did a video
not too long ago explaining why but
we are now dealing with something that
I wasn't sure we were going to see it
all and I wouldn't have expected it from
who it's happening with
actually had considered doing a video
talking about scabbing scab work what is
a scab earlier into the strike the
reason I didn't was because I didn't
have a anything to point to that was
anything anybody knew like there was
some drama with some jackass on Tick
Tock who was like oh I'm gonna I'm gonna
sweep in and take all the actors jobs
but like outside of tick tock nobody
knows who this guy was it wasn't worth
doing that so any example I would have
given would have been either way in the
past or it would have been hypothetical
I was like ah heck with it well
odds are a good chunk of people know who
Drew Barrymore is
and so uh I'm not going to use her to
explain what scabbing is and what she's
done and how she is indeed a scab
a scab when we are talking about strikes
and Union work is anybody who comes in
to do work that would normally be done
by a union member the union members who
are currently striking now scabs usually
are non-union members but it is very
possible for a union member to scap
basically the strike is in place
so the union members aren't supposed to
be working at all and a scab would
either apply to any union members who
continue to do the work they're supposed
to be striking on or any non-union
people who come in and do that work
while the union members are doing a work
stoppage those are scabs
and Drew Barrymore has announced the
return of her talk show the Drew
Barrymore show for its fourth season
and that has gone down very
badly because it is in violation of the
strike order and it makes Drew Barrymore
her producers
and whoever else she's getting to work
on the thing into scabs why would
somebody scab
money is the short reason and I have no
doubt that money is the reason she's
doing this I'm not trying to talk about
her motives but like
that's the reason to do this instead of
you know obey the strike orders to make
the money so I'm about to explain a
little bit about why someone would be a
scab please understand this next section
doesn't actually strictly apply to Drew
Barrymore I'm going to talk about why a
worker would do that scab work in her
case she is functioning more as the
employer and why the employer would scab
or hire scabs is very straightforward
they want the work done and they'll hire
whoever they can to get it done so I'm
going to talk briefly about the people
who actually do the work this doesn't
apply to Barrymore in specific but we're
going to take the opportunity to cover
our definitions now if you're going to
scab if you're going to do the work that
should be stopped because the union is
striking there is money to be had in the
short term actually in the sometimes
very short term because while the doors
are the doors are indeed wide open for
hey there's a lot of work that needs to
be done and the people who normally do
it aren't doing it will pay someone to
just come in and do it so it gets done
oh yeah there's money to be made for as
long as the strike lasts
soon as the strike is over scabs will be
ejected because you're not going to have
non-union workers on a Union Gig like
that and not unless they are working on
membership and have otherwise been
vouched for by members of the union and
no scab is ever going to be vouched for
and more to the point you scab you are
going to be barred from entry into that
Union ever again if you're already a
member and you're scabbing you're going
to get expelled from the union and not
allowed to rejoin it and come back again
so if you're trying to make money
scabbing it's a very short-term grift
because you're going to come in and do
it for however long the strike less but
then you are basically completely out of
this occupation after that other than
the non-union version of that work
that's just what you'll do forever if
you want to keep trying to do that so
while there is profit to be made in
being a scab it's brief it's generally
considered to not be worth it because
especially with something like writing
like this is a this is a career gig this
is a passion career this is something
that people want to do and take
seriously
so if you're the kind of person who's
happy to just come in and go yeah I'll
bang out some scripts for you and you
don't care about never getting that kind
of work again
there's probably a reason you weren't
able to make it to get into the Union
prior to this
now here's the funny thing about
scabbing on the one hand it's easy to
explain I already did it that's the
video we end it there no because it gets
complicated in the specifics because the
ins and outs of specific Union
regulations Union guidelines what
exactly is uh the contract that's up to
being renegotiated it gets weird and
messy so I am going to go into some more
detail and clarify exactly how Drew
Barrymore by restarting her show is in
violation of the strikes the first thing
is uh people may have noticed that she
is officially in violation of the wga
The Writer's Guild of America with
restarting the show but she's not in
violation of sag-aftra which is the
actors Union
why is that she is an actor isn't she
she's wigs she's with sag-aftra why
isn't it a violation of both well again
unions can be complicated so funny thing
while a number of major contracts were
up and trying to renegotiate them is the
sticking point and the reason why the
strike has happened not every kind of
performance is covered by the sections
currently under strike because that's
you know scripted films television
streaming Etc but there is a separate uh
kind of contract I believe they call it
the net code which covers things such as
talk show hosts which while Drew
Barrymore is also an actress in the
capacity that she hosts the Drew
Barrymore show that is a talk show host
gig and that contract for those kinds of
performers was settled last year so she
is allowed to come in and host and that
is not a violation of what she is meant
to do or not do as a member of sag aftra
but it is still a violation of the wga
so why is that well
because it's a wga show it's worth
noting especially if you actually watch
Drew Barrymore's show that
this is considered entertainment and
it's contracts for writers because it
absolutely does have them as
conversational as the show may be with
her talking to guests and whatnot this
is still a wga contracted gig now uh an
interesting comparison that's worth
bringing up this was brought up on
Twitter there's actually a fantastic
Twitter thread I will link to it in the
description that goes into a lot of this
in in more granular detail if you want
that but in short to make a comparison
to something like the Today Show or Good
Morning America which are continuing
while those structurally bear a lot of
similarities to Drew Barrymore's show in
terms of like sitting down talking about
events that have happened the news of
the day bring somebody in to talk about
a thing structurally they are very
similar they are handled under separate
contracts because the people who do
those shows are journalists journalists
have a different Union they are not
striking talk shows such as Barrymore's
because she is not a journalist it's not
a news show and she is not employing
journalists it is being handled under
wga contracts so regardless of how it
might resemble a news show that is being
allowed to continue in structure or even
in substance the nature of who is making
it and the
um unions that the people who have
worked on the show have been in make it
a wga show and it is also a struck show
it is under the strike order now
Barrymore has said she is going to start
up regardless and she seems to be aware
that there are going to be consequences
of this
ah I don't think she will reverse course
uh between when I shoot this and when it
goes up but uh I wouldn't be shocked if
she backpedals within the upcoming weeks
but I don't know we'll see hey it's Vera
from the editing phase so uh she didn't
back down but kind of the opposite
happened there are now Rumblings of
other shows such as the Jennifer Hudson
show and the talk that may also resume
in violation of the strike order so
rather than being a case of the backlash
getting her to back off we might
actually have a bit of a David zaslub
situation where he got held responsible
for the failure to release the
background movie and a bunch of stuff
being taken off of the max streaming
service that now can't be accessed at
all and despite all the outcry that
happened other streamers basically took
it as a queue of oh somebody else broke
the dam on this now we can just do it
too and we don't have to take the heat
of being the first one not what I
expected to happen but it looks like
where we're going but she basically
we launched live in a global pandemic
our show was built for sensitive times
and has only functioned through what the
real world is going through in real time
that's a nice sentiment and all but that
has no bearing on the fact that it's
still a struck show
now as I said this is a show that
normally has wga writers involved and so
you might be wondering well okay if
she's not
bringing in non-union writers to do the
writing and they're putting on the show
anyway
is that still a violation like how well
somebody's doing writing there's a
teleprompter
there are notes there's information
gathered and provided to Barrymore to be
able to host and do the show
that is wga writing not all forms of wga
writing is a movie script
and so whoever is doing that
is scabbing whether it be baremore
herself her producers other Executives
some random person they pulled in off
the street whoever's doing it is
scabbing and Drew Barrymore making
decisions the decision to move forward
in that fashion
is scabbing
now she's going to be in
pretty severe trouble whether she's the
one actually doing any of the writing or
not she's going to be in even bigger
trouble if she is but even if the
writing does not notably suffer on the
Drew Barrymore show
it's still
now a scab production
and whoever's doing the writing which
may or may not come forward I strongly
suspect that no one will be credited
with it but that doesn't mean it isn't
happening it has to be because literally
anything written down as notes
commentary monologue uh the teleprompter
whatever
that's writing
that's what's not happening so whoever's
doing it
yeah that's if those names ever get
found out they're in big trouble again I
suspect it it might well be Barrymore
herself and or some of her producers but
then that brings us to who else gets in
trouble for this
because the main thing that you know the
main retaliation point is going to be
whoever's actually doing the scabbing
which is you know the people doing the
writing now
what happens to uh Barrymore and the
rest of things after this it's hard to
say there is a potential for her writers
to not come back or for the union to not
certify the show in future and to say to
its members no that's not a cleared gig
will they take it that far I don't know
but
actually moving forward I think was
honestly just a huge mistake because
like there's been people who've taught
who've talked against the strikes Steve
Amal had some not great things to say
about the strike and he has basically
been on the apology tour ever since Bill
Maher said something incredibly
ungrateful things about his writing
staff and made it very clear the kind of
contempt that he holds them in and does
not appreciate their work at all
and I honestly kind of hope that his
writing staff quits
but neither of those are scabbing
they're allowed to say that they don't
think the strike is a good idea or in
the case of Bill Maher that they don't
think their writers should
be paid
well
I oh
I can't with that guy anyway they're
certainly allowed to say that and while
it may get frowned upon and while
they're uh their ties to those unions
might be strained and they might get a
private reprimand they can say these
things but actually moving forward with
a production actually going you know
what you said that we can't do this well
I'm gonna do it anyway
it's the arrogance of that to think that
you are somehow so special
and so
Exempted
from what it is that is going on
we have navigated difficult times since
we first came on air and so I take a
step forward to start season four Once
Again with an astute humility
all right I'm gonna say something that
immediately retracted
to Barrymore's credit
she is saying she's going to format the
show in a way that sort of uh goes along
at least with sag actra's guidelines I
own this choice we are in compliance
with not discussing or promoting film
and television that is struck of any
kind now I said that is to her credit
I'm now immediately going to retract
that because I don't think that's being
done
um to out of genuine solidarity because
if she actually had proper solidarity
and was supporting the strike she
wouldn't be screwing over the writer's
Guild
she is showing that either she has no
respect for either Union but just knows
how to claim she's doing good by at
least one of them or it shows that she
only has respect for the actors Union
and because she is allowed to still host
she is showing her utter contempt uh for
the writers Union it's one of the two
and I suspect that the way that she laid
it out in terms of saying like and we
we're gonna go with guidelines and like
all these things and I'm familiar with
the guidelines they're what I'm going by
in terms of avoiding promotional stuff
and for a talk show that's a very
relevant thing because a very standard
bit on a show like hers would be to
bring in the stars the directors talk
about the movie like saying she's not
gonna do that it would be following
Union
um requesting guidelines for a talk show
accept the show itself is struck because
it is produced by a subsidiary of CBS
along with barramore's own production
company and broadcast on CBS and CBS is
a struck Network it's a struck
production it's a struct show you don't
get to do this it doesn't matter how
what you do differs from what other
people do or why you know you think well
we've gone through all these these tough
times or like yo well I'm gonna do it
myself or whatever rationale you have
for why you think it's okay it's not
that's not how it works struck work and
a struck show means that work that is
being struck in this case the writing
doesn't happen and if it does regardless
of who does it
that is crossing the picket line that is
being hiring and enabling
scabs
I thought I was gonna have more to say
turns out to not be that much it's
actually pretty astonishingly
straightforward
given how quickly Stephen Mel had to
backpedal granted he's not as big a name
as Drew Barrymore but given that and the
backlash and the fact that the wga
itself has come forward and made it very
clear this show is struck and adds to
that some people actually picketed
directly outside of filming of the show
some audience members who were in there
they were removed by security because
they were wearing Pro writers strike
t-shirts
so far as I am aware
at time of recording they did not cause
a disturbance they simply were wearing
those shirts and they were removed
how much the writers Union can retaliate
directly is kind of unclear at least to
the show overall because it's any
contract with it will be covered under
whatever is eventually negotiated
between the wga and the amptp but this
is costing her an awful lot of respect
definitely a ton of it within the
industry and even from outside of it
because a lot of people have thrown a
lot of support even if it's only just
saying we are behind this behind the
strike and to see someone like Drew
Barrymore just go
oh well I'm gonna keep doing my show
it's okay though no
you're not special
you're not Exempted
the things that are allowed to move
forward are things from smaller Studios
independent Productions
who have made their own
specific deals and have set their own
contracts with the wga and sagafra but
the studios covered by the amptp which
CBS is doesn't matter how nice you are
doesn't matter how much people love your
show it doesn't matter how good your
intentions are or whether you're just
trying to you know make everything
bright and happy and help people through
hard times it doesn't matter I want to
be there to provide what writers do so
well which is a way to bring us together
or help us make sense of The Human
Experience it's just disappointing
Drew Barrymore
what are your thoughts on all this
she's a scab I'd normally like caveat
that with the Asterix and like an
allegedly like no she's flat outside
she's continuing the show she's crossing
the pick line she is by definition she
is it's one of those things where there
isn't a lot uh nearly as much nuances
tends to be going into this but it I
just had to get this off my chest
what are your thoughts on this whatever
they are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it patreon
pays the bills enables me to do this as
my living even if you can't help me out
that way like share subscribe are also a
big help but don't worry too much about
it
what I really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are the council I am just running
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
shout out to the patrons who help make
this possible in particular I want to
thank Robin Moore Zubin fulla goddess
Elida to rock the thing that goes joint
in the anime Ruth Oliver B solitary
pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen Auntie
Kate 808 Becky Sparks pranabilox the
poodle Robin Powell t love Tracy scravid
angry Casper Dave Hall and Rosalind
Bennett there's being able to hear me
try and pronounce your name plus a whole
bunch of other rewards on the patreon
you can check out the tiers but um
if you're already on the list thank you
so much
[Music]
oh